well welcome to converting a monolithic
application to a more domain driven
design my name is bill penberthien
i'm a dot-net developer advocate with
aws that means
my job focus is really on working with
net developers
and helping them understand how to best
take advantage of aws services
we then kind of take the interaction and
the feedback that we get from that
we take it back to our internal service
teams and we work with them to help them
make sure that our net developer
experience gets better
so also there were some uh earlier
sessions from yesterday where there's
some overlap with the talk that i'm
getting today
and i think if you look at all three of
those together they they make an
interesting story
ann and sarah for example did one on
common quandaries
implementing your first event driven
architecture and hassam did one on
practical domain driven design with ef
core
and i think both of those give
additional insight into this subject
so if you missed them yesterday i
strongly suggest that you uh
you watch the recordings when they
become available
so here's the agenda for the day um
we're going to first spend a little bit
of time defining domain-driven design
uh just to ensure that we're all on the
same page we'll then talk about some
different technical approaches to doing
the refactor
basically refactoring design patterns
after that we're going to
set the stage by talking about our
fictional demo company
and kind of describe the application
that we're going to talk about
converting
then we'll go over how to plan and how
to process through that refactoring
so we have a lot to do so i'm going to
just kind of jump right in there
i'm also just want to let you know the
way that i have everything set up right
now i don't see the actual
chat window for uh for slack
so i probably won't be all that quick at
responding to any questions
so what is domain driven design um they
have whole conferences on it and they've
got organizations based to it so
so it's actually a pretty complex
subject and i'm going to rip through it
in about six minutes
so i'll probably end up creating more
questions and i'll answer but i at least
want to get some
some of the language established that
we're going to be using as we move
forward
so what is domain driven design um
i've seen it referred to as a system
design approach which is basically the
first bullet there
it's also referred to as a as a way of
helping to understand priority
because of its emphasis on building out
the most important
core areas first
lastly you know it's also considered a
set of patterns for building enterprise
applications
in my mind it's kind of all three it's a
it's a design paradigm
that requires an as complete as possible
understanding of the business
its life cycle and how that applies to
the system that we're managing
so there's four concepts that we're
going to go over first the domain
the model the context and the business
and ubiquitous language
so the first is domain the domain is the
sphere of influence
or activity the subject area that drives
the creation or refactoring
of any applications that are that the
business needs
um simply put the the domain is
everything that your company does
this also means that no matter how
similar different companies in the same
industry may be
their domains may be slightly different
the next core concept is a model i mean
this is a pretty simple definition a
model is the set of concepts that will
be implemented in the software
the domain model then would be a set of
concepts that
that define the domain that will be
implemented in the software
but this is really different from how
model often ends up being defined which
is
basically as a class um this is
especially prevalent when you think
about frameworks like
mvc or mvvm where m equals model and is
just kind of represented by a single
class that you pass to a view
this model is much higher level instead
these class files interfaces and other
code constructs
all basically work together to define
the model the set of concepts that we're
trying to implement
the next is context so there's two
levels of context
the first simply context
is the setting around which terminology
is defined in this case it's our domain
every domain model lives in precisely
one context
and a context contains precisely one
domain model
the next level of context is a bounded
context
the context becomes bounded when it's
defined to the level of providing
explicit boundaries around a set of
models
sometimes called subdomain models a lot
of words a lot of use of the word model
there isn't there
there can be multiple bounded contexts
within a single context
just as there could be multiple sub
domain models that exist within an
overall domain model
so let's consider a retail sales company
uh one bounded context could be
the consumer sales that they're doing
another bounded context could be
the system that manages the product
inventory
a third could be the system that manages
their orders and invoicing
all of these are sets of explicit
boundaries around a set of
specific sub-domain models and they
identify and define the rules to which
each of those subdomain models must
adhere
these different bounded contexts then
may need to communicate with each other
so the e-commerce system needs to get
order information to the sales and order
processing
and the inventory system must know about
that as well because you want to update
the availability of the product
this whole relationship is within the
context
so we need to make sure that we use the
same terminology across these bounded
contexts
and that same terminology is the
business or ubiquitous language
so when working in domain driven design
we want to build a domain model that
captures the problem domain of the uh
of the systems being built we're going
to express that
understanding in code and other software
artifacts
to help us do that it's important that
the
that the domain experts and developers
really consciously communicate using the
concepts within the models
so this means that the domain experts
don't really describe a new user story
in terms of a
of a field on a screen or a menu item
they instead talk about the underlying
property or behavior that's required on
a domain object
similarly the developers don't talk
about new instance variables of a class
or columns in a database table
they instead use this ubiquitous
language
and this is critical because if an idea
can't easily be expressed
using the ubiquitous language then it
indicates a concept that's missing in
the domain model
this means the team needs to work
together to figure out what that missing
concept is
once this has been established then the
new field on the screen or the column in
the database table follows on from that
it becomes clear what that should look
like the ubiquitous language
already describes that relationship
so let's take a look at how some of
these relationships work out
on the left you have a team i i work at
amazon so we would call that a two pizza
team
the team is made up of both domain
experts for the business
and the delivery team which would be
developers dbas
qa you know pms and whatever roles you
have for your organization
so this team works to create the shared
language
while working through their domain
knowledge the domain knowledge
is distilled into the bounded contexts
and described in terms of the ubiquitous
language
each of the each of the bounded contexts
has relationships with other bounded
contexts which are defined around the
various subdomains that were identified
through the ubiquitous language
so now that you know some of the words
let's look at some of the
common implementation approaches that
are recommended as part of domain driven
design
so these are some of the implementation
recommendations that we're going to go
over
each of these you'll pretty much have
heard as being common in domain driven
design
microservices messaging eventual
consistency
command query responsibility segregation
or cqrs
and event sourcing
so microservices you know there's
there's really no single definition for
microservices that i found
there are instead a set of defining
characteristics
some of which i've listed on this slide
um like a microservice
processes communications over a network
using an agnostic protocol such as http
uh microservices are generally organized
around business capabilities
other descriptions of them is that they
tend to be smaller and more limited in
scope
message enabled part of a bounded
context independently deployed
and responsible for its own data
so i saw some definitions for
microservice
that that i felt were a little bit
confusing so i wanted to point out that
a microservice is not
a layer within a monolithic application
for example a web controller or the
backend for front end
rather it's a it's a self-contained
piece of business functionality with
clear interfaces
and may you know through its own
internal components
implement its own layered architecture
but it's important to remember that
domain driven
design does not require microservices
you can build an application that
can be called monolithic through the use
of domain driven
design practices however
microservices provide a relatively easy
way to ensure that the bounded contexts
stay distinct crossing those boundaries
when using microservices requires a much
greater intent
than would be necessary if it was simply
a monolith using an in-process namespace
difference
and i want to go into a little bit more
detail about the responsible for its own
data
because this is one of the areas that i
had the most difficult truly buying into
um i was a sql server guy
normalization to me serves a purpose
allowing a microservice to be
responsible for the data that it cares
about was okay that made sense
until you realize that some other
bounded context also cared about some of
that data
and that they might be they may both be
storing that data separately
and perhaps with different data designs
because they care about different parts
of that data
and even in different databases and and
not just different databases like
like what you can do in sql server but
perhaps one of them is storing it in a
nosql system while the other one is
storing it in a relational database
but i came around and and we'll talk
about this a bit more when we get to
eventual consistency
so the next subject we're going to talk
about is messaging
messaging is a system and architectural
approach
that allows for communications between
multiple interested parties
there are many different examples of
messaging platforms including
rabbitmq apache kafka
and some of our various aws products
there are different behavioral
approaches such as pub sub or message
queues
but what they provide to domain driven
design cannot be overstated
first a a messaging system decouples
providers from consumers
this means that a consumer does not have
to know where they uh
where to go to find information that
they care about they just need to be
able to recognize that information
kind of as it goes by so they can pull
it out and act on it
the second is that the use of messaging
provides simple horizontal scaling
if the machines that are handling
messages are being overworked you can
simply add more
the next is platform and language
integration
there's no need for the message sender
and the message receiver to be written
in the same language
or running on the same operating system
or using the same framework
they can be completely discreet and
different operations
a messaging queue also provides reliable
communications because it typically
takes a a
a store and forward approach
where the message is stored in the queue
and then forwarded to all of the
subscribed listeners
so messaging is an ideal approach when
needing to work with disconnected
systems
especially that may not always have
communications
using a store and forward approach means
that regardless of
when the system connects to the network
they're able to catch up on all of the
messages that they may have missed
and the last is that a messaging system
automatically acts as a mediator
so with the mediator pattern
communication between bounded context is
encapsulated within a mediator object
those subdomains no longer communicate
directly with each other
but instead communicate through the
mediator this reduces the dependencies
between communicating systems and
thereby reducing coupling
with this if an application becomes
disconnected
from the others that need only to
reconnect to the messaging system
not all of the other messaging
applications and i've seen
instances where a consumer could be
listening to
messages from from a couple different
systems
imagine what it'd be like trying to
connect to those each individually
so the next important concept when
considering the implementation of domain
driven design
is reliance on eventual consistency
instead of strong consistency
not every bounded context has to know
everything about the models within the
other bounded context at all times
instead they may simply need to know
some of the things if you look at the
time graph on the slide
the column of green dots demonstrates
strong consistency
so a system with a single shared
database would have
all the data is stored in a single place
and so it becomes available to every
other consumer of data at the same time
once the save is committed everyone
knows about it
the only real lack of consistency
between the customer and the product
record would be the
milliseconds of that database
transaction eventual consistency is
different
this is the staggered orange dots it
means the data will be consistent
eventually
there will be some time before all of
the other systems understand that data
and that meaning of eventually is
something that you consider when you
architect out your systems
so eventual consistency is important for
not only domain driven design but in
in my mind in any effort that expects
decoupling
it's because it provides the service the
most control over itself
the first print bullet here pretty much
tells the main story
if strong consistency was required a
two-bounded context
needed to know the same information at
the same time
that means that either one of the
bounded contexts has to know enough
knowledge about the other
so they can go get that information from
it or
they both access the same data store
kind of like what we talked about
earlier
doing that means that changes in one
domain such as to that table or to the
service that one
that the one microservice may have been
calling to another those
all could impact the domain
so the next item is command query
responsibility segregation
so this came around because of two
driving forces
collaboration and stillness
collaboration refers to those
circumstances
where multiple users will be using and
modifying the same set of data
and that's that's whether or not the
actual intention is that the users
collaborate with each other
it's just the fact that they're sharing
that same data pretty much at the same
time
so there are often rules which indicate
which user could perform which kind of
modification
and modifications that may be acceptable
in one case may not be acceptable in
another that's all collaboration
stillness refers to the fact that in
that collaborative environment
once data has been shown to a user that
same data may have
been changed by another actor so by
default it's stale
almost any system which makes use of a
cache for example is serving stale data
even though they're doing it for
performance reasons
if the data we're going to be showing
users a stale anyway
is it really necessary to go to the
master database and get it from there
it seems like you know since you'd be
pulling it in you'd be pulling out you'd
probably be mapping the domain
object to a to a dto object and then
mapping it to a
to a view model object seems like we're
doing an unnecessary amount of work
based on the assumption that reusing
code that's already been written
is easier than just solving the problem
at hand
instead let's try a different approach
how about we create an additional data
store whose data is a bit out of sync
with the master repository
i mean the data we're showing the user
is stale anyway
so why not reflect that in the data
store itself
so with that kind of a concept command
is an action taken
that adds edits or deletes data from the
primary data store
a query on the other hand pulls out a
read-only snapshot of the data
in either a primary or a second their uh
secondary data store
and so in cqrs basically you split the
uh
the definition about what you're doing
with that model into either a command
i'm gonna add edit or delete it or i
just want to look at it
the query
so there's some benefits to using cqrs
these benefits include independent
scaling optimized data schema
separation of concern and simpler
queries by separating these two you
allow them to be managed differently
you can scale each differently or use
different schemas
such as more normalized data for reads
and that will tend to lead to simpler
queries because if that's the approach
you're taking
you're not going to have to do to worry
about joins when you're doing your
queries
so segregating the read and write sides
can also result in models that are more
maintainable and flexible
know for example generally most of the
complex business logic goes into the
right model
the read model can be relatively simple
but there's also some real challenges to
cqrs
the first is it's complex
it may not be necessary um
it's a lot of work to do cqrs and many
times it just may be overkill
adding to that it's important to
remember that's
to define cqrs at a bounded context
level rather than as a domain-wide
implementation pattern
not every bounded context will need cqrs
so allowing each bounded context
to manage its own data read write rules
will provide the most flexibility going
forward
another challenge is updating schemas
and data during a release especially
when the read and write are
significantly
different imagine you're doing a release
and one of the things that you have to
do is update the value of a status field
what does that mean in this kind of an
approach so
all of these are worth evaluating if
you're considering cqrs for a project
so event sourcing according to martin
fowler the fundamental idea of event
sourcing
is that of um let me read it here
ensuring every change to the state of an
application is captured
in an event object in that these event
objects are themselves stored in the
sequence they were applied
for the same lifetime as the application
state itself
so basically event sourcing is a process
where all
changes to application state are stored
as a sequence of events
this could really sound like a stinker
because a typical application has a lot
going on with it
however you think about the other
concepts that we've already talked about
such as
messaging eventual consistency in cqrs
you'll see that there's the likelihood
that many of these events are
already being created for each bounded
context
so implementation of storing these
events is
is almost trivial because you're already
doing it
event sourcing provides several layers
of information
the first is to really be able to
identify at any point in time the state
of
any piece of data the second is that you
have recovery built in
restoring an old well-known database and
then re-running all of the messages that
were played
will put that data in that database into
the proper stage
and since it's replaying it you actually
if you design your eventing
properly have the ability to
retroactively fix errors
so think about that for a moment you
know
with the current design say of a single
monolithic database managing it
an error in business logic somewhere can
lead to bad data
say that we made a change in a in a
product service where the request
to change the product inventory because
of the sale resulted in the inventory
count being
increased rather than decreased that
would be difficult to fix
with event sourcing after you fix the
business logic
you can restore the older database and
rerun all of the events for that data
since the budget the the business logic
is fixed
the values will all be updated correctly
so your data's been repaired
you know yes if there's a lot of events
it may take a while to do that process
but i can almost guarantee you that'll
be faster and more likely to be correct
than trying to understand and fix those
area
those errors in some other way
so there are some requirements that
event sourcing does a good job of
fulfilling
the first is if you want to capture the
intent of the data
an example of this would be say
changes to a customer entity that are
captured as a series of specific events
such as a moved home or closed account
or something like that
that kind of intent can also be captured
along with all of the data changes
another reason to use event sourcing is
if you need to minimize the occurrence
of conflicting updates
event sourcing can help prevent
concurrent updates from causing
conflicts
because it avoids the requirements to
directly update objects in the data
store
however the domain model really must
still be designed
so that it can protect itself from the
requests that might result in an
inconsistent state
the next reason and one i think i
actually mentioned last slide
is that if you're already using events
within your system
you're already mostly there you may need
to tweak some of the events
as well as add some additional events
that you may not have been managing
but if the infrastructure is already
there and being used then your
implementation path is already much
simpler
and the last item i tossed on the list
was if you want the flexibility to
change
data format changing the messaging
schema is pretty simple
and interpreting the changes can be
easier as well
now if none of these items are a concern
for you then using event sourcing is
likely to add complexity for no game
um that's one of the problems that i've
seen when people that are looking to
take a domain driven design approach to
building software
is that they feel since they're doing
that they have to use all of the
buzzwords that go along with it they
have to use c
qrs they have to use event sourcing
and that's not always true many times
what i've seen is by separating the
bounded context and setting up eventual
consistency
you find that a lot of the complexity
that the original system had is no
longer necessary
because it was caused by poor boundaries
between the concepts
that means that letting each
microservice basically manage its own
data through
a crudley approach is fine and cqrs is
not necessary
or may only be necessary in one or two
highly used and highly complex bounded
context and not across the board
so we talked a little bit about ddd is
let's
take a look at some of the refactor
patterns that i've used when refactoring
applications
these strategies or refactor design
patterns or different ways in which you
can change your system
in your effort to build a domain driven
design they're certainly not a complete
list
but they offer different approaches for
refactoring systems
these patterns are also not exclusive
you'll find that as you work through the
changes
that you'll use many of these if not all
sometimes together
so these patterns that i'm sure that
you've heard of some of these if not all
are strangler fig
branched by abstraction and parallel run
the most well known of these refactor
patterns is the strangler fig
implementing this approach means that
you will create a new system
running parallel with your existing
system over time
you end up moving responsibility and
functionality from the current system
over to the new system
the primary differentiator in the
strangler fig is that it depends upon a
call from the outside of the system that
will eventually go to the new system
so the idea with the strangler fig is
that you'll replace the old monolithic
system with the new system
one piece at a time just as kind of
shown as by the image on the screen
as you can see however there's one very
big requirement for the strangler fig
pattern to be successful
that's that you have to have the ability
to clearly map the inbound functionality
that you want to refactor if your code
being migrated is deeper
or there are existing calls coming to it
from both inside and outside of your
application
then the strangler fig is probably not
your best approach
instead evaluate the branch by
abstraction pattern
this is very similar to the strangler
fig pattern however the strangler fig
pattern depends upon external calls
coming into the system
while the branch by abstraction approach
works completely within your system
and does not require any changes to the
systems outside the application being
refactored
you know i've seen where a lot of people
kind of combine both of these patterns
and architectural approaches and call it
the strangler pattern or sometimes the
strangler fig pattern
but they're really uniquely different
approaches to solving complex
refactorings
and i think it's important to delineate
between the two
because of the different implications
they have as to how you're going to
implement them
in the branch by abstraction you
determine what functionality is going to
be removed
and then build an abstraction for it you
slide that abstraction into the code and
ensure that all your consuming code is
is is basically calling that abstraction
you know once you've made sure that all
of that code
is calling the abstraction you can start
replacing that initial implementation
with the new one so i've seen this
approach used multiple times
most commonly when implementing a
repository for data persistence
so by abstracting out all the credly
calls you can switch in and out
databases
or even uh persist through rest services
instead
so the next pattern is parallel run so
strangler fig and branch by abstraction
basically allow old and new code to
coexist in production at the same time
however you generally only run one path
at a time
generally there'd be a switch somewhere
say in the
configuration or even in the database
that tells the system to use either the
newer
old branches of the code if the new
branch breaks
you switch back to the old one and
everything should just be running like
it was before
parallel run takes this a bit different
in that it runs through both the old
and the new code at the same time and
then compares the results
i mean it sounds a little crazy but
consider the situation
where your current state is a big old
monolith and you want to move to
microservices
and in traditional domain driven design
you want each microservice or bounded
context
to be responsible for its own data
management
this means that you'll be implementing
both new business logic as well as
database design
implementing new database systems
parallel run would be a really good way
to test the system
let the system you know works do the
heavy lifting
but completely exercise the new system
as if it's also doing the work
and then compare the results your
comparison engine could be as simple as
a sql script to compare data
or it could be as complex as a fully
running service that's listening to
database calls and event queues
and comparing them to what the expected
results are whatever makes the most
sense based off of the changes you've
made
your internal systems and the kind of
architectural approaches that you're
taking
you know the last time i used this
approach we were able to find a whole
lot of edge cases that were missing when
building the application
some of those edge cases we missed by
design
but there were a lot more that we had
missed coincidentally that no one had
ever thought about the details involved
in that edge case
also you know we found several instances
where the current system
or the previously running system was
actually doing work incorrectly it's
just that no one had noticed it yet
so there are three additional design
patterns that i tend to go over
in the full day session of this but
simply don't have the time now
um the first is ui composition this is
an implementation approach that takes
advantage of the various ui
implementation patterns such as mvp mvc
mvvm so that new functionality is added
or replaced by
by splitting the calls at the ui level
and splicing the results back into the
data being presented in the ui
basically you split out the data from
the new service that's being deployed
and in your management framework such as
the controller and mvc
you call the new service and stitch that
data back into the data being presented
back to the ui
this can happen with new information
using a new design
driven or a domain driven design service
or existing information that's being
refactored somehow
into a different area the next pattern
is the change data capture approach
in which we listen to and react to
changes in the data
you know this is generally a transitive
pattern it's something that you kind of
implement for a while during your
conversion
but it can also become part of your
strategic move to a more domain driven
design approach
especially in in systems where there are
more than one application that listens
to various data tables
and some of those may be ones that you
don't have any control over like
installed apps
so many database systems give you the
ability to be notified when a data table
is changed
you use this notification to perform
additional work
for example in one system i worked on we
used sql server
to notify a process that would then take
the data that had changed and cue up a
message in the messaging system that we
were using
the last design pattern is the
decorating collaborator approach
this approach uses the decorator design
pattern to take advantage
of the results of the code so if any of
you've written an http handler for iis
then you've implemented a type of
decorating collaborator especially if
you've done it on the http result rather
than the http request
if you're not running iis then this
would normally be done by creating a
proxy between the caller and the code
then that proxy would be responsible for
calling the collaborator
with the results from the response
so we've talked a little bit about ddd
and some of the patterns to think about
as you're doing refactor
let's kind of set the stage for the demo
app that we're going to walk through um
this is important because you need to
get some of that ubiquitous language for
these conversations
so our company is an e-commerce company
that sells widgets
these widgets can come in different
sizes colors it can be provided by
multiple manufacturers
there are several different sales
approaches taken by the business
for example the business sells directly
to consumers
through the forward-facing section of
the website the company also sells
through joint marketplaces like
amazon and a couple other through apis
that are managed within
the inventory module of the system the
company also acts as a distributor to
other retailers where we provide
quantities of product at discounted
prices through uh through a b2b
marketplace basically you know
case quantities on wholesale discount
there are multiple other modules there's
a purchasing module that the purchasing
and receiving department uses to manage
purchase orders
to find the inventory that's received
and account for incoming product
there's a module built for order
fulfillment that
handles things like pick lists and the
capture of the shipping information
there's a module that's only used three
to four times a year by the
by the warehouse staff to audit
inventory
there's even a module for the customer
service staff that they use to manage
customer interactions
you know whether they're purchases
returns billing issues problems anything
like that
now this may seem like a lot of things
going on because we've pretty much
talked at least
seven different business areas so far
however it's pretty normal
um you know you'll see this kind of
evolution through systems
as companies grow they'll start off with
a smaller system they'll add in a new
module
they'll add in another module that's
kind of how you get these monolithic
approaches over time
another similar approach to this is
where rather than building multiple
modules within a single monolithic
application so in this case one big
website
uh companies can take approaches where
they build different systems for each
so rather than having one big system you
have a whole bunch of medium sized
systems
we're not going to talk about that
because that tends to take a slightly
different
approach to refactoring because of just
the way that you have to manage
prioritization
so with what we talked about a really a
rough system diagram kind of looks like
this there's a centralized data store
that stores all of the transactional
data across all of these systems
there's a layer of web services that
handle all of the work necessary
within that area and note i didn't say
domain though i may have in a more
casual conversation that's just because
i'm trying to reserve that word for
for this whole conference this whole
thing that we're going through right now
um and there's also a lot more services
than these of course this is just some
of the more obvious ones
on the right hand side is a bunch of
servers which kind of represents the
load balance big old web app
and if we look at some of the
communications that are going on within
within these services
it starts to look like this so yes the
big old web app calls a lot of these
different services
but there's also a large amount of
service to service calling going on as
well
so imagine how scary it could be to try
to figure out how to add some uh
new functionality into the purchasing
module in the big old web app
how do you wedge that in amongst some of
the other rules with the current design
approach
anything you do for one module can
potentially affect other modules
what this diagram also shows is how
business rules tend to get scattered
amongst
different areas of the system in this
case there's some orchestration going on
in the big old web app as it
as it determines what services to call
when and with what information
as well as all of the inner
communications going on within the
services
you know there's more likes there
there's more likely decisions being made
in the
big old web app around processing the
order
and if the orchestration or management
is not done in the big old web app
then it's most likely done in some other
service which counts for all of this
other communication that's going on in
our service
so is that the best way to do this
probably not so let's continue and let's
take a quick look at the database design
the slide shows a list of uh some of the
tables on
well on the on the left sorry i'm so
used to standing in front of the
presentation it kind of threw me off
there
so a list of some of the tables on the
left and a partial rendition of the
database diagram on the right
what does this show well first that
there's a single database that contains
all of the information for the company
second
i'd like to say that there's at least
some separation of concern because at
least there's different schemas like
orders
purchasing products and website
see that little yellow box there that's
the most used table in the system
the users table it has lots of foreign
key references to it because of the
created by column that is
present in a lot of the tables but not
all of them
however there's also some relationships
that don't have foreign key definitions
let's look closer at the orders and
order details area that the three tables
that are in the green there
the order details only has one foreign
key in it and that's to the orders table
there are no foreign keys to the product
table or the size
table or the color table or any of the
other tables where you may expect to
have relationships
the reasons for this decision is lost in
time
but it probably had something to do with
some refactor or redesign
somewhere along the way which meant that
historical orders would not be able to
support the foreign key relationship
so it just simply wasn't added
and there's all sorts of these little
code smells throughout the application
and to be honest probably in every
long-standing application that i've ever
worked on
so so we should judge this one too
harshly
so there are really two serial processes
going on
this slide shows the order in which they
go and and what service has the
responsibility of running them
the first is on the website as it builds
out the required information namely the
user customer and payment then sends
that to the order service
the website then empties out the
shopping cart
once the call gets to the order service
it turns around and calls the product
service to update the inventory
calls the communication service to send
order confirmation email
and somewhere along the way it's doing
its own processing as well
so to support those seven steps in the
order float the communication flow looks
something like this
other business flows are very similar
everything that's going on in the big
web application
talks to other services and then those
services talk amongst themselves as they
try to
get the appropriate information that
they need to build out their own
requirements
you know in some of them the website
does some orchestration and then hands
it off to the service
the service persists it somehow and then
performs additional processing based off
of whatever additional business rules
were defined for that service
so this is all we're going to refactor
so how do we even start to fix this
first
let's find the rules that we're going to
work under
the first and this rule should be very
obvious is to take a very incremental
approach
do not try and deliver everything at
once
in fact incrementing both horizontally
and vertically is okay
the most important consideration is that
you make continuous progress
the next rule and probably even more
obvious in the last
is that you must continue to support the
old ways of doing things
since there's so much interaction
between services it's likely that there
will be uh
other things going on that are either
missed unknown or you just haven't had a
chance to get to yet
next is to make smart technology
decisions as you go through the process
i know some of you are kind of looking
at me about that
but i've seen a tendency to look small
when looking at these technology
decisions
votes like um
just enough to get by or i'll add that
later
they end up leaving you with as much
tech debt as you already have now
remember to plan for tomorrow's work
next quarter's work
and next year's work and make the best
technology decision as possible
this doesn't mean that all of these
decisions have to be implemented now
however what this means is they need to
be accounted and planned for
it's perfectly okay to say i want to
move this order service away from sql
server
to a nosql database because i figure
that'll more easily support the future
changes that the business sees
and not do that work until you want to
make those future changes
but make the decision as early as
possible and make your design and
architectural decisions around that
end goal and how you plan to get there
that's going to help you understand
which of those
domain driven design patterns that we
talked about uh
cqrs or all that
how they're going to fit in with your
overall system
the next is don't be afraid to change
the way things are done
uh that you historically perhaps did all
of your data access through stored
procedures doesn't mean that you have to
do that moving forward
instead take the time to evaluate your
current implementation approach against
your end goal
some of what you have done could just be
picked up and moved other existing
approaches
may simply need to be scrapped and
redone you should never put yourself
into a place where
that's how we have always done it
becomes an acceptable answer
lastly and i'm harping on it again but
build that ubiquitous language
cooperatively across all of the teams
agree on the language and stick to it
change the language as needed but do it
together
even if everything else turns into a
into a big old smelly bag and nope
having the language in itself will make
the whole effort seem more worthwhile
even if the only time that you're using
it is to yell at each other in the
in the retrospective meetings at least
you'll be speaking the same language
so i would keep these rules in the back
of your mind as you start determine
strategies for your refactor
so one of the easiest ways to start
building your ubiquitous language is to
build your context in bounded contexts
in this case we're going to define the
context as the website
and it's supporting functionality so for
this company
everything um the boundary contexts then
become
the different business areas or domains
or subdomains um
many of you probably have considered the
phrase domains and subdivisions before
so remember that a
that a bounded context is the same as a
subdomain
in this case we have listed product
customer purchasing
order and geography well there are many
many others
when you evaluate your own context i
would recommend you stay away from
reinforcing the constructs that you
that your system already has built into
it step back
and actually evaluate what's going on
within the in the domain in the context
remember one of the key points for this
is building your ubiquitous language
define and describe what needs to go on
to support the business
and don't be afraid redefine terminology
as you go through it
in many ways this may make it easier
let's say you currently have a
a quote service that performs a series
of actions
if you determine that the things that
that service cares about is correct
then perhaps you can call it a quote in
the new system
because it implies the same
responsibilities
if however you need to change the
behavior i recommend that you
rename your ubiquitous language to
something new
maybe estimate or something else that
describes the new set of behaviors and
responsibilities
you know this is especially important
because
almost by definition a monolithic
application
has had some domain creep uh
you know an example say your quote knows
what order number that it
that it was used for now is your time to
fix this
you'll see that even visualizing using a
uh using a bounded context approach is a
different way to look at your business
it seems less rigid it also makes you
look at the responsibilities of the
bounded context as a whole
and not necessarily as part of a
distributed system
once you have some ideas around your
bounded contexts
the next thing is to define the
communication between
the different bounded contexts with the
subset shown on the slide
we know the purchasing bounding context
has to get information from the product
bounded context
and i gotta stop saying bounded context
because it's just killing me
so the customer gets information from
the order and geography
order gets information from customer and
product
why because it makes sense uh they have
a relationship between them what does
purchasing do
if it doesn't relate to products or what
is what are orders without products
so as you build out these communication
streams pay attention to the three
important details about the
communications
what each of the context needs to know
why they need to know it
and when they need to know it because
understanding those key bits will help
us design our system
so i pulled out the communications
between product and purchasing
i use this is the example because of how
it shows how domains could be different
uh for different companies the way that
this company defined
um their business is that the product is
the most
important thing and then they will find
out the best place to buy the product
to purchase it many other companies that
i've worked with have a different
approach
where the purchasing domain actually
provides the the product to the products
domain
so the purchasing domain is actually
responsible for creating the product
and then providing that to the product
domain this one is different it takes
the other approach the product
bounded context is responsible for
creating the product
and then allowing that to be sold
through the purchasing bound context
so in this particular case the product
bounded context kind of
um just lets the purchase bounding
context by sending this
pieces of information in the message
so here's how this relationship in the
current system
is currently defined in the database uh
the half with the
with the color is the purchasing schema
the right side is the product schema
there's just a single foreign key
relationship from the purchase order
details table in the purchasing schema
to the product table in the product
schema if you take a look at the product
table
you'll see that it has three tables
directly related to it with a couple of
those related to other tables
this means that a fully instantiated
object graph of a product is going to be
pretty gnarly
and it's hard to imagine that the
purchasing systems needs all of that
information
and it doesn't so while it needs a few
more pieces of information that
we showed here it's only a small
fraction of the overall object graph
basically so that the purchasing agent
can fill out the purchasing order
but it's been identified that's what the
context needs and that's why it needs it
the last question is when in this case
does a purchasing context need strong
consistency or does eventual consistency
work
what kind of lag can your system
tolerate between
when the product context knows about
when a newer change
product happens and when the purchasing
context knows about it
the more tolerance you have the more
eventually consistency
the more eventual consistency is
appropriate
so back to how to plan your refactor
so we talked about describing context
and defining communications what why and
when
the next step is determining the most
critical core area of your application
and to find it in detail
if you remember back to the earlier
slide on ddd
it used the phrase a way of focusing on
core areas for
design consideration and emphasis that's
what we do now
determine those core areas some of this
will be
at the infrastructure level such as
defining sending and receiving messages
others will be more domain level
as you go into your refactor there are a
couple of items you have to do
as you as part of your planning process
the first and most important is to
define your critical area
um this most likely will include several
bounded contexts
this could also be spread across
multiple systems and once you've
identified those critical areas
define the communications between each
part
and then start breaking that chain of
dependencies
remember this process
and the communication schema that looked
like this
would an approach like this make more
sense assuming that eventual consistency
is okay with the business need
this could mean solving this problem the
user website places an order
the website bounded context says
relevant information about that order
it then sends an order placed message
orders and products are both listening
for order place messages
the order takes that message saves all
of the information locally
and does whatever other business
activities need to happen
the product also takes that message but
since all it really cares about is the
product id and quantity that was ordered
it just takes those pieces of
information and decrements the quantity
of available product
and if evolution of the business means
that some other domain is identified and
added to the ubiquitous language that
cares about an order being placed
then you just add that in as well and
you don't affect any of the already
existing code
none of that has to be changed so
rolling in that new functionality
is pretty much as low risk as you can
get
unlike what you would have to do if
you're going to make that change in the
current version
say adding in a new step into the
process that the web has to perform
and since the change is happening on the
website it has the potential of
affecting
all of the other steps of the process
that are happening on the website
so the risk of that change is much
higher than using the new design
we know that the website calls multiple
services as part of its processing
such as the order user and payment so
let's talk about those two highlighted
systems and how they should change
so this is what our goal system looks
like the website will pass information
along to the website service
the website service will persist that
information that the website thinks is
irrelevant
and then queue up a message containing
that data the order service
rather than being directly called by the
big old web app
is now listening to the message queue
for messages that fit the appropriate
criteria
so we're adding two new constructs here
the website service
and it's attached storage in this case
amazon aurora and the message queue
we're changing the big old web
application by removing all of the
business process that it was doing and
moving that into the
processing into the website service
we're changing the order service so that
it listens to the message queue for
order created messages
so the work that needs to be done
refactor the website to remove business
process
create the new website service to do
website domain work
and refactor order service uh to listen
to message queue
so this is pretty much what the website
looks now there's a a bunch of
client-side logic in that hippie
language javascript there's a controller
layer that accepts the user input
it returns the ui elements and there's a
business logic layer that does all of
the processing and orchestration
that's what we're going to move so
ideally
a lot of this would be easy to move
because we already have an abstraction
layer between the controller and the
business logic
i don't know if i would necessarily call
it a repository but other some kind of
interface layer a service layer or
something like that if you do then it's
pretty easy to replace the current
implementation
with a layer that calls the website
where this business logic will move to
if there isn't however we did go over a
refactor pattern that would help with
that
the branch by abstraction in this case
you would add the abstraction layer
between the controllers and the business
logic assuming that it's not already
there
once you get that done and can verify
that all of the communications between
the controller and the business logic
are passing through that abstraction
layer
you can then refactor the previous
business layer to instead call the new
website service
so right about now you may be
questioning my decision to create a new
website service
so this is one of the most common
decisions that people make and
and i would argue incorrectly is to
perform any kind of business logic in
the website system itself
instead add a new layer of abstraction
to the whole kit and caboodle
um and use that to
as your as your first step for this
reprocessing and refactoring
and then especially because this
provides scaling um if business logic
processing is expensive and the ui
rendering is not
then you can scale them differently
you're already starting to get some
gains for your
for your separation and it'll also
decrease your uh
your risk of changes to the system as
you move forward by decoupling the
presentation the business logic even
further than you would in a traditional
mvc approach
each can grow and be managed on their
own
so this is a higher level view of the
current order service
it's pretty straightforward there's the
defined api that includes the endpoints
called from the website
the business logic and the persistence
layer
when you consider this design what kind
of changes do you envision that would
have to make for it
so let's take a look at one approach
that you could do to make that work
so this is what an idea of what the
order service would need to look like
afterwards
first we need to add a message handler
so this is going to pay attention to the
message queue
and react to the order created messages
that come through and whatever other
messages we end up caring about
conceptually you wouldn't have to change
the api at all that the endpoints for
creating the order still exist or
okay you know especially if there's
other systems that maybe call that
endpoint
that's not something that's happening in
our case here because of the big
monolithic app
but in one of those systems where there
may be multiple applications that are
doing it
you could just keep that api there until
you've had a chance to refactor those
other systems
we'll also need to add a messaging layer
to process any outbound messages if
we're going to be setting anything
um and then we would need to refactor
the business logic layer
so if we remember this approach you'll
see that the order service
did the processing to update the product
inventory and to send the order
confirmation email
but it doesn't have to do that um
because those services will already know
about them
because they're smart that way because
you made the same types of changes to
them
this work seems intimidating there's a
lot of changes to go through
it'll be frustrating it'll take you way
longer than you expect
however it's doable i've done this
several times myself
and as long as you concentrate on
understanding your domain
building your ubiquitous language
differentiating your bounded context
become clear
and in my mind that's the hardest part
finding the communication between these
bounded contexts as well as the business
rules
you know within the bounded context
helps you understand the appropriateness
of specific implementation approaches
such as
cqrs messaging and eventual consistency
within
each individual bounded constant or
context
after understanding all of that
it really seems that writing the code is
simply an
implementation detail
i know we try to cover a lot of things
in a short period i appreciate you
sticking with me
especially since we couldn't get as deep
into the weeds as i imagined some of you
were hoping
some of those earlier talks that i
mentioned to did go a little bit deeper
so once again i say
i recommend go take a look at those so
thank you
uh and don't forget to come over to the
aws booth and if you haven't already
registered for the drawing for
star wars lego come and do it
thank you